and ponder the question
[Music]
what if
time that is black panther space that's
captain marvel reality that is iron man
ah we're being flunked through a
tournament of alternative universe space
shards this is so unsafe behold the
triangle of
convenience of course you would be
humble classic star-lord putting classic
in front of anyone's name also known as
a classic sin t'challa has unwaveringly
balanced korath on one shoulder as if
he's a baby about to be burped sure he
works out and practices hand-to-hand
combat but he's just a normal man and
hauling dead weight around should not be
this easy not one of these well-armored
fighters decides to shoot out t'challa's
knees not one though our hero's destiny
might lie in the stars above the
beginning of his journey was much more
down to earth previously on black
panther also is living in a rich
technologically advanced fantasy land
like wakanda really more down to earth i
mean it's on earth i guess but still
it's [ __ ] wakanda does this really
look like peter quilty y'all sure i
don't know all humans look alike to me
that's racist well my home is built on
an ancient vibranium media right secret
spilling kids but why stop at one world
huh
when we can show you all of them this
kid is zipped up into orbit by a
kid-snatching alien and doesn't shed a
single tier for the loss of the
relationships he leaves behind why is
t'challa so chill about his impending
abduction your money is no good here
please no seriously we only take cash
then why not just start with that saying
your money's no good here and we only
take cash are two very different things
it's implication which is not something
drax would ever do he's just brutally
honest also how are they able to get
just about everyone back to voice their
characters they played in the
live-action films we couldn't get dave
bautista to voice drax was he too busy
pitching stupor too remember nebula is
just a cartoon remember nebula is just a
cartoon remember nebulas when i was
young yondu attempted to return me to
wakanda but
it had been destroyed t'challa knows
nebulan works with her father from time
to time she should already know this
story no i get that we don't know this
story but there has to be a less sinful
way to get it exposited to us and then
you ask but even if there was wouldn't
you send the exposition anyways and yes
yes we absolutely would standing
directly in this blinding light beam
never have been any good at saying no to
you kid this is probably the first time
in the history of parenting that never
saying no has resulted in a responsible
adult i mean if you consider an adult
who robs people blind responsible so
yeah you should say no to your kids
sometimes parents the collector's got a
famous kink for exotic flora and fauna
dendrophilia and no there's nothing
wrong with a healthy fetish i just love
saying dendrophilia stop i thought we
were faking it shouting your plan at
this volume near the people you are
trying to trick ravagers will start the
riot drawing the attention of the black
order we have a situation all units
report to our position all units report
because one guy was chucked across a
courtyard that was hardly a riot and the
only reason this works is because of the
this works cliche amazing i have no
notes a perfect plan no notes how about
the glaringly obvious question of where
will we find the embers of genesis
inside the [ __ ] maze the show tells
us the answer is to accidentally run
into a duck that gives directions
perfect plan my ass oh my dearest nebula
aren't you aside for a sore
i forgive me i couldn't help myself the
collector would be a marvel at tv sense
sure most everyone is seeing t'challa
find living collections and thinking
about their story or purpose but i'm
over here wondering how the collector
feeds them all or cleans out their cages
or what is the food bill for this many
living creatures my guess he's
compensating for something big man
marvel is really trying hard to make
howard the duck of thing in this
universe i like getting weird as much as
the next guy but i still have scars from
trying to wrap my little kid brain
around leah thompson begging for some
duct tape i don't need those wounds
opened up again you know i can find them
the cosmic floor down the hall says the
duck in a moving prison maze who somehow
knows where a very specific item is
located destroyed talking loudly
discharging a weapon having no general
plan of where you're going i mean the
list of reasons why t'tal is doing a
terrible job just grows and grows you
know what they say when you're out of
luck always go duck or my personal
favorite if it don't quack don't give a
[ __ ] the ravagers
it's a diversion only one person of this
highly trained deadly gang knows what
the ravagers look like ah yes wakanda
tech so advanced that it glows like
daylight to really hammer home that the
necklace matches the vehicle t'challa is
so lucky too because the model of his
necklace includes the glow even brighter
mode if he hesitates to follow the
plotline
i mean t'challa is correct but he can't
possibly know that yet the homing beacon
could have been sent years ago and
wakanda could have still been destroyed
both things can be true you don't belong
down there with them you belong up here
with us with your family justifying
kidnapping all a distraction providing
me the necessary cover to obtain this
the embers of genesis but the show won't
bother us with showing us how she
actually did it that would be just silly
the collector would be smart enough to
remove anything from a person that could
be used as a weapon but of course he
doesn't here because reasons i liked
that thing you said about not locking
people in cages that's what it took to
convince karina not the thousands of
individuals that were kidnapped and
locked in cages before t'challa it's
good she came to her senses and took a
stand but damn it took a long time to
get there there's plenty more we can
play with observe collector fans prepare
yourselves for several minutes of op
weapons in fan fiction fighting i warn
you so you can get your mental
masturbatory sock ready a dagger forced
in dark matter taken from the ruler of
the dark elves reminding me that thor
the dark world is a thing that exists
just a reminder as t'challa somehow
manages to launch himself backwards a
hundred feet do the splits midair and
snatch a crown off ahead that he's just
human these perfectly symmetrical
chaotic eyebrows don't you love how the
wall of weapons fire reduces to a few
shots once the enemies are in sight also
our heroes can escape and have a few
boss battles my point is if you have an
army of bad guys blasting the [ __ ] out
of a place one second why would they
stop when they turn the corner first if
yondu had just put the whistle missile
through the collector's head this would
be done by now second did he just knock
off hell's helmet and it shatters sort
of lame powerful helmet takes a tumble
off a noggin and disintegrates see kids
this is why you never eat watermelon
seeds do you think this can contain me
at this point i'll believe whatever you
show me thanos is decent nebula is a
blonde pressing buttons on an arm cuff
you've never used before can open a very
specific door to the nearest nifty jail
cell none of this matters because it's
not in the timeline i've been investing
in in i [ __ ] hate it the collector
magically has the bracelet back on that
yondu took off of him i was the one who
told you i wanted to see the world all
you did was show me
the universe oh i see we've arrived at
the last act where conflict simply fades
and we're eating the crumbs of the
remaining resolution to the story i
don't want crumbs i want a sandwich
where you want to be
that's the question didn't it better
question how did he know which button
was the show me the earth button on a
wakandan ship but that's a story for
another day is it a story that will
almost entirely be people saying trust
me this thing we're doing is super hard
and then skipping over how they managed
to actually do the hard things because i
just watched that episode i'm not
interested in round two
you know when you go on like this what
you sound like
that's gonna leave a mark look at me
sure i'm the captain now
that's it
no more mr nice duck
you don't belong down there with them
you belong up here with us with your
family there's always room for family i
gotta get some of that green stuff
no
not that green stuff
all you did was show me
the universe i should have been a better
father to you dewey i wish
i spent more time playing catch with you
and less time training my body and mind
to kill you in a machete fight